let's get right into things with the
coronavirus obviously there was the
announcement of the lottery
uh last week over at allegion stadium uh
how confident are you that this is going
to be
the nudge to get more nevadans
vaccinated yeah well it was a raffle
incentive program
it's not a lottery you got to make that
clear to comply with nrs
uh i'm very confident i'm hopeful that
people will see it for what it is
it's it goes over eight weeks it's going
to give folks an opportunity to be
entered eight times to win a
series of prizes all culminating with
the grand prize and
in eight weeks which should be a million
dollars to one individual so
it's certainly an incentive to get
people to to get their vaccination if
they haven't gotten it yet and those
that all got their vaccine will also be
entered
so that gives them the fairness of the
you know because they got it when they
were available to them
so people have been very positive about
it um
i think it might be worth it worth
clarifying again where this money is
coming from given the financial
constraints of the state for people that
maybe don't know the machinations where
is the money for the
raffle coming from yeah thank you i
appreciate that the money is coming from
our federal allocation
that it was made clear the money that
the federal government gave to each of
the states
to use in fighting coronavirus and
getting vaccines and getting testing
and setting up protocols and ppe and all
that sort of thing
it's coming from the pot of money that
they gave us for that for dealing with
covet
so it's not like it could be put back
into the rainy day fund or could go
towards other myriad things that are
needed in nevada right now
yeah no it can't and there are a myriad
of things that are needed absolutely but
this
money is limited there all the money
that we get from the federal government
is usually your market is pretty much
constricted it's siloed
in the certain areas as the same with
this money
speaking of things that are needed in
the state at the state of the state
address at the beginning of the year
you had several sort of key issues one
of them being innovation zones
it didn't happen at the legislative
session right
try and go ahead
i was just going to ask again to try and
articulate if you can what happened
between state of the state and the end
of the session where the innovation zone
up in story county
didn't happen you know basically we ran
out of time i still think an innovation
zone is a potentially great idea
uh if we need to change things that are
happening in nevada and we do
we need to change how we're funding
education we need to change the
diversity in the jobs that we have
we need to change you know our forward
thinking i think an innovation offers an
opportunity
we made it into a study where it's going
to be manned by people from the
legislature to to sit down and
understand the
intricacies of it it's an important
issue
it deals with a lot of different areas
but you have to address the
tax revenue and the water situation and
the housing costs and the infrastructure
costs
in all of those things and the way the
legislature was going
when it wasn't open to the public and
you couldn't get in and then when people
were allowed to call in for a public
comment it was limited to two minutes
and
you know per person and 30 minutes total
it wasn't conducive
to something of this magnitude so i'm
hopeful that during this time here
before the next
legislative session that they'll take
the time to really research this
and understand and put in the time that
we did to uh
fully vet what an innovation zone would
be and the benefits that come from it
and hopefully come to the right decision
i'm wondering what conversations you and
your staff had with the people in story
county before
the state of the state because following
that and through the legislative session
at least in my discussions with the
county manager and others up there
they felt completely out of the loop and
obviously they're not happy with the
idea of if this goes forward the way it
was presented initially
it would be self it would be
self-autonomous self-governing and would
be
isolated from essentially story county
well we do the best we can to maintain
communications with all 17 counties and
that's just that there's just one or two
of them
there's 17 counties that we try to stay
in contact with
i know that the people that were
advocating for the innovation zones met
with story county
some of the legislators that you
represent those areas
were involved in the discussion and we
had the discussions that we possibly
could now can you ever have enough
discussions
no that's why the problem he had with a
short session when we're only there for
120 days
also with the restrictions related to
kovid i couldn't call a meeting where i
had you know 25 people come in
to the governor's office or the capitol
and say okay let's all sit around the
table here and talk about
the benefits of an innovation zone and
what it would provide to the state
because of the protocols that were in
place so hopefully we'll be able to do
that
in the future and get people understand
exactly the benefits that it is because
story county would benefit
tremendously as a result of what
individual innovation zone would bring
and acknowledging the restrictions made
it hard to do
and still makes it hard to do a lot of
things right now but it just would seem
to me that if this was
sort of the one of the three main things
that were mentioned
in your state of the state it would have
been worthwhile to at least talk to the
folks who live there
well we did have conversations as i will
say there weren't enough conversations
either way they did not express their uh
displeasure with it to me either early
on so
we found out a lot as we went along and
we tried to adjust for that but
it's tough when you have a session
that's limited to 120 days and there's
so many bills coming out of the
legislature
that we just couldn't get this one on
the front burner fast
enough to make those calls final
question on this um
acknowledging there's a study going on
on this but uh
would you see a zone like this happening
where the self-governing aspect of it is
gone
is that is that a deal breaker
essentially well i don't know the one
the issues you've got is they want
control and these are part of the
discussion has to be brought forward
somebody doesn't
invest billions of dollars into a
development once some say so
over the zoning as it relates to that
over the type of development that's
going to relate to that
type of schools that are going to be in
there they want some input on that and
you can see what we have in southern
nevada
with a master plan community this is
bigger than that
and we're familiar with it in southern
nevada it's not something that they
experience up in story county
so those are good points but we're going
to have to have that discussion but we
have to start thinking
of ways to change our economy to change
the way things are going
and i think innovation zones offer that
potential you got a lot of money that's
on the sidelines around the world
that we could attract to come to nevada
and it creates
tens of thousands of jobs people lose
sight of that i mean we're talking about
an economy that's been hit devastatingly
in terms of loss of jobs all over the
state and this would give people an
opportunity to go back to work and make
a living
i'm going to get back to the
unemployment issue in a second but first
another issue from the legislative
session uh
measures regarding the death penalty um
you oppose the death penalty there is a
death penalty case that will likely be
delayed but it's
you know there's an execution sort of on
the relatively immediate horizon here
how do you feel about the department of
corrections
using experimental drug cocktails for
uh for the death penalty in nevada and
do you
would you like the state to alter what
qualifies
for it even if the death penalty isn't
abolished well that
you've got several questions in there i
can't speak as it relates to the zane
floyd
case that uh the d.a is bringing forward
because that's under litigation right
now
and that's working its way through the
courts and and hopefully they'll come to
a resolution in terms of how to deal
with it quickly
as it relates to the issue uh that came
before me in carson city or didn't get
to my desk
i was that that issue never came to my
office prior to the legislative session
in terms of trying to understand what
would be a palatable for me in my
administration what we'd accept and what
we wouldn't
it came out of the legislative session
and i have some cases
having gone through one october
personally
i am not a strong supporter of the death
penalty being used
as often as it's being used right now
but in the worst of the worst cases
like we had at one october i think that
that option should be made available so
we'd have to make some type of uh
accommodation for concerns but here
again
that is such a groundbreaking issue it's
so crucial
people are so passionate on both sides
of that issue
that you need to have a thorough vetting
of that question
and you can't do that when you have zoom
calls
and people are limited to two minutes of
conversation and you can only get
10 or 15 people into the conversation to
voice their opinion
uh we needed to have the opportunity to
have extensive meetings as it relates to
that
and this just didn't happen this
legislative session
and one of the other issues that was
maybe you would suggest
delayed by zoom calls and so forth is
the ongoing issue with dieter and
unemployment there's been i don't know
three or four
i i forget the number of people who are
at the head of dieter
since the beginning of the pandemic
and there are still issues that people
have with getting their their benefits
taken care of
um what needs to be done and what's
taking so long
well dieter is uh a major problem i
don't think anyone can deny that
but you're finding out across the
country that the estimates are fifty
percent
of the cases that were applied for odor
benefits were fraudulent
i mean hundreds of millions of dollars
were applied for and money got paid out
on fraudulent claims
and we need to do more in concert with
the attorney general department of
justice to prosecute those people
that all being said we uh inherited a
broken
system that was never set up to handle
anywhere near
the capacity that came in as a result of
the pandemic
we put people in there the system
crashed we fixed it it crashed we fixed
it it crashed
and we did what we can to deal with
people but those are skilled positions
that people need to be trained for in
order to evaluate claims
we're getting them out as fast as we
possibly can
uh it was unfortunate that it's taken
this long but
this is a common problem all over the
country i'm not making excuses for it
but i'm saying that we need to fix the
system
completely so that next time we run into
a situation where the system is strained
or put under the stress
it won't totally break down in the
beginning of the pandemic
there was a lot happening resorts
closing down the strip
everything it was everything was falling
apart it seemed
and obviously dieter is a crucial
component of that if people don't have
benefits and they have to pay their rent
pay their their
meat for their meals put food on the
table take care of their kids
couldn't the state have reallocated
assets
at the outset acknowledging the
limitations of training and so forth
but to really emphasize that early on
so that it didn't linger all the way
through
well you're mistaken there john we did
realize it early on we did allocate
additional assets from day one we
transferred people from different
apartments into that department
to try to deal with all these claims but
when you're transferring new people
you've got to train the people to deal
with these claims
and then when you've got to vet these
things to the extent that
half of them hundreds of millions of
dollars were fraudulent claims
and they made it worse for the people
that had legitimate claims so we
recognized the problem that it was
it's just not something that's easy to
fix
i know we're running a little short on
time so i'm going to try and get to a
couple of other topics real quickly here
um i want to look ahead very quickly to
the next
election i am going to assume you're
running for re-election when the time
comes
i am okay uh sheriff lombardo clark
county as you know
and north las vegas mayor john lee have
come out i'm sure things will change
you know them well you've been down here
you know how how that works
what keep what do you think are going to
be the key
issues years down the line for what your
re-election is
that might differentiate you from
whether it's mr lombardo mr lee or
whoever else might be uh
running yeah we've got two up north and
two down here so at least four people
have already said that they're running
i think what you're going to have to
look at is what somebody's plan are and
what they've done
it's easy to sit back and be a monday
morning quarterback
uh you know when you come to these
situations this state faced a pandemic
that if
it comes once in a century uh is
it's just amazing it was devastating to
our entire economy
we need to make some we needed to make
some really really hard decisions
and i needed to stay on my ground and
put in mind what was the absolute best
for all of the residents of the state of
nevada the 3.2 million people that call
nevada home
and i believe we did that and i think we
did it as best we possibly can
we're in a situation where we were
concerned about running out of body bags
that's how bad it was and how bad the
air quality could get
as it did in some areas from you know
the situation that we face it's just uh
it's very difficult to balance keeping
our
hospitals open and not overstressing our
health care system
at the same time not totally destroying
our economy
trying to keep people so that they could
pay their rent trying to keep people so
they get your food on the table
and do testing and stride up the vaccine
program we had a lot of balls in the air
at one time
and it was very very difficult to do i
think we made the best decisions we
could
based on the information that was
available at the time
and like i say it's uh i think we're
going to come out better we're going to
come out stronger
and we're going to come out uh with a
better economy and a better future
um final question here uh environmental
uh lake mead's been dropping that's been
an ongoing issue we all know with the
issue
of the water levels at lake mead um what
can the state do
there's talk as there has been of about
draining lake powell
what kind of measures can nevada take or
encourage the federal government to take
to try and make sure our water supply
isn't damaged further well that's one
thing that i'm
familiar with uh lake mead in the water
situation i spent 10 years on the county
commission i was on the water authority
for 10 years the water district for 10
years
you can't just drain lake powell into
lake mead these are issues that are
dealt with
by the department of the interior and
the blm that
that deal with those sort of situations
the best thing we can do at the state
level is conservation
we signed a bill that helps with the
southern nevada water district that's
going to remove
non-functional turf which is going to
save tens of thousands
of acre feet of water per year that's
going to help us get further along
we need to do more in terms of education
in terms of
uh saving the water that we do have and
not wasting it now most of the water
used inside of your house
is reclaimed it's put back through the
system it's put back in the lake we take
it back out again
but uh the water we use outside we don't
get back
so we need to do more in terms of what's
going to be allowed
what's going to be uh where we can serve
more and
and that's done a lot at the state level
but a lot of that is in the local
jurisdictions as well
some might suggest that las vegas over
the last 20 years or so has done a
pretty
good job of starting to conserve and
that the real drain on the colorado is
further upstream so is there anything
that you as governor can do to encourage
farmers up north and other states or to
stop uh sapping so much from the
colorado well you know the colorado
river allocation is something that's
been uh
in place for many many many years nobody
is going to get that
people say well why don't you get an
increased allocation from the colorado
river
that would be all well and good but for
us to get increased allocation we'd have
to take it from somebody else
because there's no more water coming
down the colorado nobody wants to give
up
their water that's the old western
saying you drink whiskey and you fight
over water
i mean that that's the situation that
we're in we need to help
people use the water efficiently we are
currently in a situation where the lake
is dropping but there's not an
immediate danger to anybody certainly in
southern nevada clark county we don't
use
our whole allocation of the colorado
river so there's still room for growth
reasonable growth and we just need to be
more cognizant of it but i think this
shows you
when you see what's happening with the
lake when you see what's happening with
the temperature when you walk outside
this afternoon
global warming is real it's here and
it's affecting our way of life
last question you mentioned at the
beginning of the discussion the lottery
the raffle for the coronavirus
i've been here long enough
we how far does nevada have to go
to recover how long of a recovery
talking about here
well i don't have a magic number if
that's what you're talking about in
terms of people getting vaccinated no no
i i guess i'm talking more more
financially more from an economic
standpoint here
we i mean how hard the las vegas in
particular was hit
how long did you get back we i've
apologized for talking over
we've been hit extremely hard no doubt
in southern nevada but i'm in constant
communication
with our resort community with our small
businesses with our chambers and so
forth and so on
we lost some jobs we're bringing them
back i can tell you our economy is
really starting to heat up i think
you're going to see a very very rapid
recovery
in our convention business going into
the third and fourth quarters
going into 2022 you're going to see a
lot more of that
and and we need to do what we can to
facilitate that you know as we get more
international travel coming back
you're going to see people coming to las
vegas uh the resorts are doing
well now on the weekends i mean they've
got people coming in whether they're
coming from california or wherever
locally the areas but during the week we
need more conventions and meetings
coming
and we do have a lot more booked in the
third and fourth quarter we had
uh the world of concrete was here a
couple weeks back and we had a big uh
barrett-jackson auto auction at the
convention center last weekend and that
all brings people into our economy but i
think you're going to see us
emerge and rebound very very strongly as
we put more and more people back to work
and the economy builds on itself i was
going to ask that's one of the
challenges is people say there aren't
enough people
applying for jobs they're short staffed
up and down throughout the valley
yep it is and it's difficult we do have
a labor shortage in some areas we've got
a
a child care shortage which is one of
the reasons people aren't going back to
work
you know they have a place you know
you've got two kids you gotta have a
place to send them our schools aren't
open yet they're all for the summer
break
so as we get into i think august
september and kids are going back to
school and
jobs are available you'll see a lot more
happening
all right governor i know you've got to
run i appreciate the time we should do
this more often i appreciate it very
much
thanks for the time forward thanks a lot
appreciate john have a great one
take care